[Música]
eeuu y los países europeos miembros del
consejo de seguridad de la onu
condenaron la interceptación de un avión
de ryanair por parte de belarús y el
posterior arresto del opositor romar
contra ceviche rusia por su parte
defiende el actuar de su aliado el
presidente bielorruso alexandr
lukashenko dijo que actuó conforme a la
ley internacional
colombia vive una nueva jornada de paro
nacional convocado por sindicatos y
organizaciones sociales aunque con una
asistencia mermada la jornada es un
abrebocas de una nueva movilización
masiva prevista para el día viernes
cuando se cumple un mes de este paro en
el país la alcaldesa de bogotá claudia
lópez entregó un informe ante las
naciones unidas sobre las presuntas
violaciones de derechos humanos
el ex asesor del gobierno británico o
doble joven se aseguró que el fracaso
del primer ministro boris johnson en el
manejo de la pandemia cobró
innecesariamente la vida de decenas de
miles de personas se mostró arrepentido
por los errores cometidos y pidió perdón
a las familias de las víctimas johnson
rechazó estos señalamientos y defendió
su gestión de la crisis sanitaria
tenemos recortes
muy buenas noches gracias por continuar
con nosotros en france 24 si raúl blanco
como siempre un gusto saludarlos
comenzamos continúan las reacciones tras
el incidente del vuelo comercial de
ryanair que cubría la ruta entre atenas
y vilna y que fue obligado a aterrizar
en belarús estonia francia irlanda
noruega reino unido bélgica alemania y
eeuu integrantes del consejo de
seguridad de la onu condenaron el hecho
y lo calificaron un flagrante ataque a
la seguridad de la aviación civil
internacional y la seguridad europea la
acción del consejo de seguridad es poco
probable dicen los diplomáticos porque
rusia con un poder de veto puede
proteger a su aliado belarús tras este
hecho un vuelo minks barcelona tuvo que
dar media vuelta después de que francia
prohibiera el uso de su espacio aéreo
esto como parte de las sanciones
impuestas por la unión europea contra
belarús por esta detención del
periodista opositor román podrá ser
hecho
si hacemos un llamado a la organización
de aviación civil internacional para que
investigue urgentemente este incidente
inaceptable y sin precedentes y para que
los responsables rindan cuentas por
completo
[Música]
release o viste tratarse de exigimos la
liberación inmediata del señor
protosevich periodista independiente de
belarús y de la señora se apega quienes
fueron detenidos por las autoridades
bielorrusas y a quienes se les impidió
abordar el avión en el aeropuerto de
minsk hacia su destino original tuits
sin lentes teenage pero por su parte el
presidente alexander lukashenko defendió
su proceder tras el aterrizaje forzoso
del avión de ryanair asegurando que
actuó conforme a la ley internacional
veamos ahora el informe al bar santana
donde nos cuenta más de las tensiones
entre occidente y belarús
en medio de la crisis diplomática entre
occidente y belarús por la detención del
periodista opositor román protosevich el
presidente lukashenko defendió el desvío
del avión que permitió la detención
alegando una amenaza de bomba y que
desconocía que protege bitch viajaba en
el avión también acoso accidente de
estrangular a su país años organizados
en punto han pasado de organizar
disturbios a estrangular la búsqueda de
nuevas vulnerabilidades sigue en marcha
y está dirigida no sólo contra nosotros
somos un campo de entrenamiento un lugar
de pruebas para ellos antes de marchar
hacia el este después de probar con
nosotros irán allí
quiero más
belarús está recibiendo presión
internacional por parte de eeuu la otan
y la unión europea por lo que califican
como un secuestro la ue que está
considerando aumentar sus sanciones
contra la nación ex soviética quiere
aislar a belarús por vía aérea con
tensiones presentes a raíz de las
polémicas elecciones en 2020 que
consolidaron el poder de 26 años de
lukashenko y generaron protestas masivas
duramente reprimidas y el maltrato
opositores como pitula surock que murió
en la cárcel el lunes ahora rusia sigue
apoyando a su tradicional aliado aunque
asegura no estar implicada en el arresto
del bloguero
nos hemos dado cuenta de la forma en la
que nuestros socios occidentales en su
mayoría y de forma abrumadora los
líderes los jefes de estado y de
gobierno los representantes oficiales y
los medios de comunicaciones comentan
esta situación como si tuviera alguna
conexión con rusia
nick of the skin en el nuevo
enfrentamiento entre belarús y occidente
la comunidad internacional exige al país
que respete los derechos humanos y ponga
en libertad a fruta ceviche cambiamos
ahora información a casi un mes del
estallido social que sacude a colombia
el país vive una nueva jornada de
protestas en varias ciudades pero con
menor asistencia de manifestantes juan
gonzález asesor de seguridad nacional
del hemisferio occidental del gobierno
estadounidense aseguró que en algún
momento se realizará una llamada entre
los presidentes de bailén a iván duque
para tratar la crisis social que
atraviesa el país
emilio archila el nuevo líder negociador
del gobierno ante el comité nacional del
paro adelantó que están trabajando en la
validación del documento al que llegaron
como pre acuerdo con el comité respecto
a las garantías de las protestas ayer se
vivió una noche de violencia donde el
palacio de justicia de la ciudad de
tuluá en el sur occidente del país fue
incendiado los manifestantes siguen
exigiendo reformas estructurales y
apoyando la moción de censura contra el
ministro de defensa diego molano
con más detalles de lo que ocurrió hoy
en colombia
nueva jornada de paro nacional en
colombia en la que ha sido denominada
por el comité nacional de paro como la
toma de capitales y que ha producido
movilizaciones en todo el país
organizaciones denuncian que la
situación continúa siendo grave con más
de 60 muertos desde el inicio del paro
nacional el 28 de abril pero también más
de 3000 heridos y centenares de
desaparecidos estos números han llamado
la atención de la comisión
interamericana de derechos humanos que
ha solicitado al gobierno de iván duque
entrar en colombia para iniciar una
investigación algo que el ejecutivo ha
negado también aquí en la alcaldía de
claudia lópez en bogotá se ha enviado un
informe a las naciones unidas donde se
detallan más de 100 vulneraciones de los
derechos humanos claudia lópez quiere
volver a llevar la iniciativa como hizo
con la gestión de la pandemia al
presidente iván duque y es que ya ha
anunciado un plan de reestructuración
del presupuesto donde el dinero iría
destinado a temas sociales como
educación y transportes este miércoles
por lo tanto ha sido la antesala de lo
que será el próximo viernes cuando se
cumple un mes de paro nacional en
colombia
y en eeuu son nueve personas incluyendo
el autor de los disparos fallecieron en
un tiroteo en el centro de san jose en
el estado de california la policía
explicó que hay varios heridos algunos
de ellos en estado grave y fueron
hallados explosivos en el lugar de los
hechos el suceso se produjo en el patio
de maniobras de la autoridad de
transporte del valle de santa clara
tiene en el centro de san josé donde
almacena y lleva a cabo las tareas de
mantenimiento de los vagones de tren
el autor que era trabajador del lugar se
suicidó tras abrir fuego y las
autoridades están investigando sus
motivaciones
en este momento con números y puedo
confirmarles que hay ocho víctimas que
se declaran fallecidas
y hay un sospechoso que se declara
fallecido que se estancó esto todavía
está en curso como dije los números
pueden cambiar por lo que ésta sigue
siendo una investigación en curso fluida
y activen en persecución cambiamos
nuevamente información nos vamos a estar
reino unido donde dominica mens el ex
asesor del primer ministro boris johnson
aseguró que el gobierno fracasó en su
manejo de la pandemia adoptando malas
decisiones
costaron la muerte innecesaria de
decenas de miles de personas las
declaraciones se produjeron durante un
interrogatorio de siete horas por
diputados de las comisiones
parlamentarias de sanidad y cuidado
social y ciencia y tecnología desde
londres nuestra corresponsal luisa
pulido tiene todos los detalles veamos
en esta explosiva y sin precedentes
comparecencia de siete horas en el
parlamento dominique ambiente aseguró
que por la incompetencia del gobierno
miles de personas murieron por ccoo y 19
que no tendrían que haber muerto afirmó
que la estrategia inicial del gobierno
fue dejar avanzar el virus hasta que se
alcanzara la inmunidad del rebaño que
inicialmente boris johnson dijo que ésta
era apenas una gripa y que pensó incluso
en hacerse inyectar el virus en
televisión para así demostrar lo que la
prioridad ha sido siempre proteger la
economía que los confinamientos aquí en
inglaterra se han decretado muy tarde y
que incluso boris johnson no es la
persona adecuada para ser primer
ministro británico pero dominica mens
fue especialmente duro letal podría
decirse con el secretario de salud más
hancock de quien dijo tuvo que haber
sido despedido del gobierno hace rato
por al menos 20 asuntos especialmente
por mentirle al público aunque de
dominica me abrió las puertas del tras
escena de los primeros días caóticos de
la pandemia aquí
el reino unido- la investigación formal
e independiente sobre el manejo de la
crisis que ha traído el kobe 19 al reino
unido- sólo iniciará en la primavera de
2022 pero estas declaraciones
seguramente serán un gran insumo
y de esta manera llegamos al final del
informativo en france 24 continúe con
nosotros para más actualizaciones de
noticias muy buenas noches y hasta
pronto
[Música]